well the brain is organized to reflect
everything you know in your life your
brain is a record of your environment so
it begs the question
does the environment control your
thinking
or does your thinking control the
environment so if you wake up every
morning and you do the same things and
you go to the same places and you see
the same people
and you react in the same way and you
perform the same behaviors
it really is the external environment
that's turning on different circuits in
your brain causing you to think equal to
everything that you know
as long as you keep thinking equal to
everything you know that's familiar and
the same according to the quantum model
you keep creating more of the same to
change then is to think greater than our
environment to think great in the
conditions in our world need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation hey
it's evan carmichael and i make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best dr joe dispenza and my take
on his top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two make new choices the
hardest part about change is not making
the same choice as you did the day
before
when you decide to make a different
choice whether it's the change of
something that you eat or to exercise or
to no longer react to certain people or
conditions in your life remember you're
going to feel uncomfortable now that's
not a bad thing that's actually a good
thing that means you're in the unknown
and when you step into the unknown
you're going through dramatic changes in
your own personal biology
when you're in that place of uncertainty
that place of unpredictability that void
that unknown ask yourself what thoughts
do you want to believe in and fire and
wire in your brain what behaviors would
you like to demonstrate that's equal to
a vision of the future close your eyes
and rehearse them review every step
no different than an athlete beginning
to rehearse what they're about to do the
act of rehearsing it begins to prime
your brain to prepare you for that
behavior in your future
and then finally
can you teach your body emotionally what
that future is going to feel like before
it happens and when you begin to fall
into the present moment and marry those
intentions with an elevated emotion your
body is believing it's living in that
future reality in the present moment and
you're changing your biology from living
in your past present reality to living
in your future present reality and your
job then is to be able to maintain that
modified state of mind and body your
entire day and if you can get ready
because something unusual is going to
happen in your life it's the law rule
number three control your emotion we may
not be able to control everything in our
outer world
but we certainly can control our inner
world
and so
it's not so important to not react i
mean everybody reacts i react the
question is
how long are you going to react
so if you keep an emotional reaction
going on for an extended period of time
you're memorizing that emotion and your
body as the unconscious mind is
believing it's living in the same past
experience 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year the
body
doesn't know the difference between the
real experience that produces the
emotion and the emotion that we create
by thought alone so then the emotion
then reaffirms the state and then people
start to use the problems and the
conditions in their life to keep that
emotion going and i would call that an
addiction so we become addicted to the
very life we don't even like
so
it's important then for people to
realize then when you have that moment
where you have crisis or something
breaks down
that you do have control over it and
it's a formula
and it's a skill and our research shows
that you can teach people how to do that
and so then when you're living by some
emotion there'll always be a gap between
the way things appear and the way things
really are emotions alter our perception
and if you act during that time
you'll always say the same thing i
should have never said that i should
have never done that i should never
thought that i should have never sent
that email
so then shortening your emotional
reactions
is a level of intelligence then that
causes you then to recalibrate because
most people don't think they have
control over that they'll say that
person did it to me that circumstance is
the reason i am this way then i would
say if something in your outer
environment is controlling your thoughts
and feelings then you're a victim to
your environment and yet
how you think and feel creates your
outer world so if you're thinking and
feeling equal to everything that's known
in your present personal reality you
keep creating more of the same so to
change then is to think and feel greater
than the conditions in your environment
and be able to do that to such a degree
then you're no longer reacting to the
same people in the same way
and that takes an effort it's it's not
easy in the beginning but once you start
practicing
uh you get better at it and just like
anything else you start to move through
your life with more coherence and you're
less likely to knee-jerk and if you're
less likely to knee-jerk then you're not
in an unconscious program rule number
four invest in yourself i think one of
the most important things when we lose
sight of our vision is to make time for
ourselves and i think that when you
invest in yourself
you invest in your future
disconnecting from people in your life
in places that you have to go and things
that you do or things that you own long
enough
to begin to reignite a vision
of how you see yourself or how you see
your future
and begin to emotionally embrace that
future
and change your state of being allows us
to see a whole new landscape if you've
lost sight of your vision
take a moment and remember that vision
and begin to emotionally embrace it and
from that state of being start to think
about the things you want to do the
choices you want to makes write them
down review the behaviors that you have
to demonstrate your goals and
experiences and how it's going to feel
when you do that enough times you're
changing your brain neurologically and
you're changing your body genetically
write down the unconscious thoughts that
you have to stay conscious of become
aware of the choices that you no longer
need to make review the behaviors and
habits you have to change about yourself
and become so conscious of them that you
won't go unconscious at all during your
day remember the experiences in your
environment that you need to stay away
from whether it's a person or a thing
just for a period of time
so that you can keep that vision alive
and most importantly
review those emotions that keep you
connected to the past and become so
conscious of them and name them when you
feel that feeling that if it's guilt or
sadness or pain the moment you start
feeling it and you become conscious of
it that's when you can begin to change
and if you keep doing this over and over
again the unlearning and the relearning
the breaking the habit of the old self
and reinventing a new self is going to
cause you to arrive at a whole new
future and when you do this could become
your new habit also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
rule number five let go of your past
you can't go to the future
holding on to the biology of your past
decide what thoughts you can bring to
your future write them down thoughts
like i can't it's too hard i'll never
change i'll start tomorrow what's wrong
with me it's someone else's fault
decide on what behaviors or actions or
unconscious habits you have to change
how do you talk do you complain do you
blame do you make excuses do you feel
sorry for yourself just become so
conscious of those behaviors that you'll
never go unconscious again
and lastly you have to decide what
emotions no longer belong in your future
that means if you want to be wealthy you
can take lack if you want to be healthy
you can't take insecurity or fear you
got to begin to condition your body to a
new mind
if you do this
every single day your personality
creates your personal reality and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel change any
one of those things and you change your
life and begin to measure the effects of
you it cause give it a shot rule number
six change your personality your
personality creates your personal
reality and your personality is made up
of how you think
how you act and how you feel
so the present personality who's
listening to this little video has
created the present personal reality
called your life
which means then if you wanted to create
a new personal reality a new life
you would have to change your
personality that means you'd have to
start thinking about what you've been
thinking about and change it it means
you'd have to become aware of your
unconscious habits and behaviors and
modify them
and you'd have to look at certain
emotions that keep you connected to
experiences in the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
your future
the beauty behind this is is that when
you begin to change how you think how
you act and how you feel you should
begin to see changes in your life and i
recommend that you try it out rule
number seven don't live in survival mode
the majority of our thoughts and
feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering our shame our unworthiness our
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion
stress
is a lot of energy that we're drawing
from our very vital life force yes a
resource of light and information and
we're turning it into chemistry and
we're literally robbing the body's
energy right so so then living like that
for the short term is okay because the
body can move back to homeostasis it can
restore itself but
when we're over doing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so
again you can eat all the right food you
can do all the right things but if
you're living in anxiety and fear and
you're viewing your world from the worst
case scenario that could possibly happen
because that's what you do in survival
there's no energy for growth and repair
there's no energy for healing so the
majority of our thoughts
are signaling certain circuits in the
brain that signal another part of the
brain the limbic brain to make what's
called a neuropeptide neuropeptides are
chemical messengers that signal hormonal
centers so now you're taking thought
and you're storing it as energy in these
energy centers and and if you're living
in survival why would you open your
heart i mean it's just not a time to
open your heart i mean if you're getting
chased by t-rex
it's not a time to meditate it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to connect
it's not a time to communicate it's not
a time to sit down and go within it's
not a time to be vulnerable it's time to
run fight or hide rule number eight
break bad habits
to change is to be greater than your
environment that means be greater than
the conditions in your life to be
greater than the circumstances in your
world and every great person in history
knew this that means you have to be
defined by a vision of the future
instead of the memories of the past
to change means to be greater than your
body those unconscious habits and
behaviors and choices that you've made
over and over again so many times that
the body becomes the mind
emotions that are connected to past
experiences keep you anchored
emotionally to the past and if those
emotions are driving your thoughts and
those thoughts are creating the same
emotions then your body has become the
mind which means that in order for you
to change you're going to have to get
greater than those emotional reactions
habits and hardwired attitudes that keep
you running unconscious programs
and to change then is to be greater than
time if you're waking up every single
day and making the same choices and
demonstrating the same behaviors and
creating the same experiences and you do
that over and over again it makes sense
that your past is going to look a lot
like your future and your future will be
more of your past finding the sweet spot
of the generous present moment existing
in that place where you're no longer
trying to predict the future
based on the past means you're in the
unknown and when you're in that place
called the eternal present moment that's
where all possibilities exist give it a
try number nine stay present think about
this if you spend the majority of your
day focusing on matter
focusing on everything in this
three-dimensional world that's made of
material things
it begs the question how much of your
time and your attention do you put on
that unified field that invisible field
of information that exists beyond space
and time
and just like
when you're unaware of your nose it
doesn't exist and the moment you become
aware of it it exists
the quantum field is exactly the same
way if you put very little attention on
it in your waking day
then it doesn't exist for you but the
moment you begin to become aware of it
the moment you begin to pay attention to
it the moment you begin to stay present
with it and to experience it moment
after moment and where you place your
attention as you learned is where you
place your energy
and where you place your attention
causes things to expand
the moment you begin to experience it
not with your senses you experience this
three-dimensional reality with your
senses but you experience it with your
consciousness and with your awareness
the moment you become pure consciousness
is the moment you make contact with that
unified field
and so we now know
the techniques and the tools to get
people beyond themselves
and in fact we know that after thousands
and thousands and thousands of brain
scans that you're at your absolute best
when you get beyond yourself
when you take your attention off your
body
when you take your attention off your
identity that's connected to people in
your life the things you own objects you
own places you have to go in time itself
the moment you become nobody no one no
thing nowhere in no time that is the
moment you become pure consciousness
and that's the moment you begin to
connect to that field of possibilities
called the unified field or the quantum
field and that field in this invisible
field of information that exists beyond
this space and time and independent of
the color of your skin
your gender your diet your sexual
preference independent of your
profession your class
independent of all those things that
create separation
that every human being has access to it
i'm rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is live by
example i always tell my advancing
students you know when you're changing
is when you stop talking about it
because when you are truly changing
you can't go to church and shake hands
and say peace be with you and then get
in your car and cut everybody off on the
way out of the parking lot you can't say
i don't like the war in iraq and be
arguing with your next door neighbor or
your co-worker
you have to be the living example of
everything you want to see in the world
in terms of change if you don't like
greed start giving
you know you have to demonstrate and
when you do
you give people permission to do the
same
because they're going to observe you
doing exactly what they're afraid to do
but they know it's the right thing to do
so the way
we transform the world is we transform
ourselves
the way you transform a culture is you
transform an individual an individual by
individual when we stop looking outside
of us and you say that world is a
reflection of some aspect of me if
everybody in the world did that
simultaneously imagine how the world
would change and it's not enough to just
focus on peace yeah there's been great
studies that have shown that when a
community of people focus on peace that
the crime rates drop
but when they leave and the research is
over the climate crime rates return back
to the ceiling value
it's not enough to just think you've got
to demonstrate it you've got to show it
in all areas of your life and when you
demonstrate it now it becomes an example
for people to follow
in order for you to to really begin to
explore the unknown aspect of yourself
you got to learn how to get beyond the
known aspect of yourself and if you keep
coming back to the known you're going to
miss out on the unknown so you would say
well i don't know anything in the
unknown of course it's the unknown and
if you try to control it there you're
back to the known if you try to predict
it you're back to the known so you've
got to go through this trial and error
of just kind of refining your attention
refining your ability and and it's just
got to be something like playing tennis
or playing golf or doing martial arts or
working out or crocheting or stance in
the salsa you just got to keep going man
in the beginning it's tedious and then
when you start finding your groove like
our our community
they don't miss their morning
meditations yeah you know why because
the magic is happening and they know if
they miss it they're gonna they're gonna
cut off from the magic so they whether
they're tired whether they're hung over
whether they're what they're right
they're in right you know and if you if
you wake up in the morning
and you can't get your butt out of bed
you know what that means it just means
you can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
your life your body's resigned
so then so then you know when you went
on a school trip when you were a kid you
know you woke up before your parents you
knew something new is going to happen
that's the body going wake up wake up
some unexpected is going to happen what
happened to us christmas day
so why not
you know put in your put in your time
and then and then measure the effects of
you would cause i mean become a
scientist in your life and really start
to experiment with it okay let me change
my energy let me just write down four
thoughts
that like i can it's too hard i'll start
tomorrow this doesn't feel right
whatever it is it's be this person's
fault just write those down and say
these thoughts like gandalf on the
bridge yes you may not pass today this
is the end yes so then if you become
conscious of those thoughts now you're
the governor of your thoughts what what
what actions what behaviors do you want
to change do you complain you blame you
judge do you make excuses how do you
talk do you speak limited just pick four
things
that you're not going to do any longer
yeah
what emotions get you in trouble what
are the emotions that you're addicted to
too right that you're addicted to that
keep you returning back to your past if
you don't know
close your eyes for about 30 minutes and
just watch where your mind goes and
watch your feelings and just say okay
it's frustration it's unworthiness it's
self-doubt it's guilt it's frustration
it's shame
just
become conscious of those and just
review them in your mind so that you
don't go unconscious them in your waking
day you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then if you say then
you're not going to live in the familiar
future familiar past or predictable
future you're not going to think about
how long you've been meditating what you
got to do you you labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now that's
greater than the program and if the
person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs and
the person starts thinking differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and yeah they
start seeing those synchronicities and
serendipity self-love is no longer about
pleasure or having a car it's something
that you're cultivating within you so
then imagine we have research to show
and this is such a this is such a
duality
that when you start seeing the brain
start synchronizing getting coherent the
front of the brain and the back of the
brain that two hemispheres coming
together and you we can say to
scientists that come and study our work
oh watch this ed's gonna pop what do you
mean just watch this is gonna be good
and all of a sudden you see this brain
going into this kind of psychic union
the heart blows wide open you see
coherence going on and you look around
at that person and there's tears running
down their face
imagine feeling so whole
that it's impossible to want i mean how
can you want when you're whole because
you feel like you already have it now
when you reach that point
that's when the magic happens because
now you are worthy to receive and the
universe only gives us what we think
we're worthy of receiving share this
with them please yeah i think i know for
me i mean
i'm curious and i'm a pragmatist i mean
if you tell me something all i want to
know is how i'm going to use it in my
life yes and i'm not in the dinner
conversation because nobody changes from
that you know i mean i'm a doer and i
want to be around doers and and who are
you and i connect so well i think and i
yeah yeah obviously and and and and uh
you you create a group of people
that are passionate about transformation
and they've they've done some of the
work when we were doing our four day
four and a half day uh advanced
workshops right around the end of the
event i was seeing people starting to
notice seeing some really great
transformations and i thought this is
the pop yeah as a pop yeah big pops yeah
and we were like we had to send them
home
and i was like oh god man if i could
just have them for a week
so we created these week-long events
where people retreat from their lives
and
they remove the constant stimulation in
their external environment that reminds
them of who they think they are as a
personality yes they separate themselves
from the people they know and the places
they go and the things that they do at a
certain amount of time in their routine
mundane life so we'll bridge a little
quantum physics with a little neural
science little neuro uh endocrinology a
little epigenetics psychoneuroimmunology
those are all sciences about possibility
and i now know that if you can give
people sound scientific information
and you know
for me that's the language
and then if they can turn to the person
next to them and explain it you're not
going to get off the hook
if you can't explain it it's not wired
in your brain but if you can build a
model and explain it you're installing
the neurological hardware in your brain
in preparation for the experience so the
more you understand what you're doing
and why
the how it gets easier because you can
assign meaning to it so then if i can
set up the conditions in the environment
and give them the proper instructions
and push the envelope a little bit yeah
and people who get their behaviors to
match their intentions and their actions
equal to their thoughts they get their
mind and body working together
they're going to have a new experience
and the experience then is not only
going to enrich the philosophical
circuits in the brain because experience
does that but it's going to produce an
emotion so they're going to start
feeling more unlimited i think that
emotions are energy in motion
and so let's just say that um
we share the same experiences okay i
don't we're friends and we share the
same experience you're from london i've
been to london my daughter lives in
london and we have hey you do this i do
that you did the you know you own this i
own that you know so what we do is we
actually look to see when we meet people
if we're matching neurologically if
we're matching emotionally so if we
share the same experiences we share the
same emotions and if we share the same
emotions we can relate to one another so
this is where it gets sticky so then the
moment you start saying ah
that person did that to you once yeah
that person i had a similar experience
to that person to that to me now
now
we open the door like i'm going to use
you to reaffirm
my
attachment to that emotion
and let's just work it up so that you
can suffer and i can suffer and then we
can have a conversation and literally
we're sharing the same energy and if
we're sharing the same energy we're
sharing the same information and we're
bound by an invisible field of energy
that keeps us connected yes so then what
does it take to break that energetic
field an energy that's greater than the
energy that's holding it together that's
how you separate atoms that become a
molecule you they're
they're bound by an invisible field of
energy that's keeping them connected so
you got to use a greater energy than the
energy that's holding them together to
separate them well in order for you to
change then you can't have energy
without awareness or consciousness you
got to go to a greater level of
consciousness and change your energy and
nobody changes jay until they change
their energy when they change their
energy they change their life so then
you may say well this person you know i
i use this person and i use my enemy to
reaffirm my addiction to hatred i use my
co-worker to reaffirm my addiction to
judgment i use my ex to reaffirm my
addiction to resentment that we have
these different people in our lives that
we need to remind us of who we think we
are the enemy dies and you find another
one
you know you know your co-worker uh
leaves and you start judging another one
it's just
it's not any it's not that so then
when there's no longer a vibrational
match
when you start doing the work
there's no longer a vibrational match
with you and your past present reality
that that person or that condition any
longer
that person or condition is going to
spiral away because you're no longer
you're no longer in need of that so then
our life begins to change when we change
our energy and we begin to take our
power back that's essential for us to
begin to create with now some people
can't handle that because
they're not conscious that they're doing
it so they'll be working on their vision
of the future
and yet they'll spend two hours
lowering their energy back into
victimization or suffering and they want
to know why their future isn't happening
well
there's an unconscious program let's go
after that and once you start going
after that
now all of a sudden your life starts to
change again so you can't say it doesn't
work
on some level we don't work and if
you're really invested in this
the question is what is it about me
where am i directing my attention or my
energy who am i using to reaffirm some
conditioning that i need to remember who
as my old self so then when you stop
reacting to the person or the person is
now complaining to you and you're not
complaining back
it's going to be an uncomfortable moment
because
you're all of a sudden seeing a part of
you
you used to be that you no longer are
and you have to be willing
to not go there and over time that
person will thank you and they'll say i
didn't even know that i was complaining
that much and
by changing yourself you help others
what thoughts do you want to fire and
wire in your brain what kind of
attention and intention
do you want to place so that that
becomes the loudest voice in your head
and if you keep practicing it the
hardware becomes a software program and
it'll say jay you can do anything jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything jay
you're unlimited you just got to hang
with it on the other side of this is
greatness whatever you want to program
in there you get the program in there if
you sat down and say how am i going to
be with my wife my husband my partner
how am i going to be with my kids i'm
going to be at work with my co-workers
how am i going to be in traffic
and you close your eyes and you begin to
rehearse in your mind if you're truly
present the brain does not know the
difference between the real life
experience and what you're imagining
so now the brain goes from a record of
the past to a map to the future now
you're installing the hardware keep
practicing it it becomes automatic comes
easier now it's a software program you
may just start behaving differently so
you ask the person why are you so
unhappy why are you so frustrated why
are you so resentful the moment you ask
that their brain is going to associate
that emotion to a past event to a memory
into a memory
that's because they have nothing to look
forward to in their future so if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it just means to me that you're
more in love with your past
than you are with the future so how do
you teach people to believe in a future
that they can't see or experience with
their senses yet but they've thought
about enough times in their mind that
their brain is literally changed to look
like the event has already occurred the
latest research in neuroscience says
that's absolutely possible we know that
and how do you teach a person
to select a new possibility in their
future and begin to emotionally embrace
that future before it's made manifest to
such a degree that their body as their
unconscious mind is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're signaling new
genes and new ways ahead of the
environment
now to their body begins to change to
look like the event has already occurred
we've proven that that's possible now
think about this so the more you think
about your desired future the joy
the gratitude the
uh
the feelings you want to have that are
more positive the more you think about
it as it's as a future thing happening
the more your body shifts now
exactly so your body is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment now think about this the
stronger the emotion you feel from some
condition in your life the more altered
you feel inside of you the more you
narrow your focus on the cause and the
brain freezes an image and takes a
snapshot and that memory now is embossed
in the brain it's branded in there so
then people think neurologically within
the circuits of those past experiences
and they feel chemically within the
boundaries of those emotions and the
stronger the betrayal the stronger the
trauma
the more the body's living in the past
right so then so how you reverse that so
now
if you truly got passionate about a
future we've all done this you get a
wild idea in your mind and you start
holding on to that vision and you're
preoccupied with it all of a sudden the
thought in your mind becomes the
experience and you start feeling the the
energy of the future now the stronger
the emotion you feel from that vision
the more you're going to pay attention
to the picture in your mind and now
you're remembering your future and vice
versa the stronger you pay attention to
the feeling of the past pain you're
going to create the pain in this moment
exactly so then so it requires a
coherent brain and we now know that
there's a formula for that and we've got
beautiful research to show that people
can do it they just have to practice and
it requires a coherent heart because
resentment frustration in patients
creates a very incoherent heart yeah and
when that heart becomes incoherent you
stop trusting yourself there's no energy
that you get you stop trusting in your
future
so then if there's physical evidence in
your brain and body
physical evidence to look like the event
has already occurred it's quite possible
you'll be thinking neurologically within
the circuits of your future
and you'll begin to feel chemically
within the boundaries of that emotion of
your future and how you think and how
you feel is your state of being
and now your state of being is living in
the future instead of the past now
the moment you disconnect from the
emotion of your future because traffic
or some co-worker or your ex or whatever
people come up with
now you're back to the energy of your
past and now you're going to start
looking for it analyzing why hasn't it
happened well if you're feeling the
emotion of your future why would you
look for it because you would feel like
it already happened and that is the
place where the magic happens so then
you can't just do this
get up and then return back to your old
state of being
you got to maintain that modified
statement
when life happens small let me finish
with a face
well of course of course i mean we all
take blows in our lives yeah and we all
react emotionally but the question is
how long are you going to reach right
right so then if you can't mediate and
regulate your emotional reactions and
those emotions linger for days that's
years for some people mood and then
months temperament
years personality trait so then the
person's personality is literally based
on the past but they don't know that
because they're doing it over and over
again it becomes a subconscious program
so now
if it requires a coherent brain and a
coherent heart then we have to train
people how to self-regulate how bad
does it have to get i mean to what
denominator
to what lowest level do you have to
reach
before people really make up their mind
to change my message is why wait i mean
when you're feeling so altered
emotionally you feel so bad that's the
moment you could actually see yourself
for the first time because you're you're
not answering your cell phone you're not
responding to all your texts you're not
watching tv you're not going out to
dinners you're not calling people back
you're something's altered in you and
you're starting to become self-aware
right
so then
people wait to that lowest moment where
they can start to see themselves through
the eyes of somebody else well if you're
waking up every day and you're combining
a clear intention with an elevated
emotion and you're changing your
emotional state to be
elevated
you could still see the old self from an
elevated point of view and be state
conscious then from a limited point of
view and that's what i want for people
like let's go i mean what do you got to
lose what people are going to start
wondering like did you change your
medication what's up with that guy
something's different about him you're
not predictable any longer right now we
say to our
our community you know when you're
changing you just stop talking about it
you're just too busy being it
something's happening you know and
that's
the repetition of getting a few days in
a row
of that really well i always say
god if you had a great meditation you
wake up feeling better
at the end of that meditation than when
you started and you do that the next day
and then the next day you're gonna start
feeling better all the time and that
your body's going to start feeling
better and everything's going to start
feeling better and you're going to start
feeling better about life look i mean we
are we're in a convenience-based society
i mean if you if you lose your internet
connection or your cell phone doesn't do
it it's supposed to people get angry
like yeah that's 20 seconds right so
here you are creating something out of
nothing
and you don't have the patience well
that has to come out because
a very very masterful person
who is abundant
had to own
impatience so then never make it be
about the end result make it be about
effort
every day you're overcoming every day
you're out of the bleachers and you're
on the field and you're giving it your
all and you're practicing keeping your
energy up greater than your habits in
your body or the emotional conditioning
of your body greater than any
circumstance in your environment and
sustaining it for an extended period of
time then all of a sudden
when you're connected to the energy of
your future
and you know what that feels like yeah
you will know the moment you return back
to the energy of your past and if you
tell me it's because of your boss your
co-worker your ex i'm going to say ah
you're back to the unconscious program
that you're the victim of your life
right so then so then it takes some
unlearning and the unlearning process is
the most important process because once
you do that
you're clearing out room for the next
creation to be easier and the next one
to be easier because you're starting to
understand the formula a little better
and you start saying i'm not going to
take that personally or i'm not going to
react or i'm not going to go back to
that person again i'm just going to
self-regulate again yeah you only need a
few experiences to know that this is the
truth and then you start making start
managing your attention you manage your
energy a lot better and i think that i i
always say i don't care that you fall
off the horse i just care when you get
back on right because some people fall
off and then they have to go into guilt
and analysis and and they take weeks and
well you could have just said i fell off
let me just get back on and keep going
here if you think about this your senses
plug you into your external environment
everything you're seeing or smelling or
tasting or feeling or hearing all of
your five senses are affecting your
brain
so if you're waking up in the morning
and you're going through the same
routine behaviors as you did the day
before
and you're not in the process of being
defined by a vision of the future
then you're for the most part left with
the old hardware in your brain from the
past as a matter of fact your brain is
organized to reflect everything you know
from the past
so as people wake up and they begin to
pay attention to their body they start
to look around in their environment they
start to do typical things
it's the external environment that's
turning on different circuits in their
brain causing them to think equal to
their environment
and if you have the idea that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny as long as you're thinking equal
to your environment you keep creating
the same reality over and over again
so to change is to think greater than
your environment to think greater than
the circumstances in your world to think
greater than the conditions in your life
and i think every great person in
history understood this they were
defined by a vision that was much bigger
than that we've done an experiment just
10 minutes a day
three times a day with 120 people
trading resentment frustration fear for
gratitude appreciation and thankfulness
measuring their immune response
the the chemical immunoglobulin a your
primary defense against bacteria and
viruses the best flu shot you'll ever
get lives innately within you turns out
when you're frustrated when you're
impatient when you're fearful the immune
system dials down because you're an
emergency it's not it's all your energy
is going for some threat in your outer
world there's no energy in your inner
world for growth and repair but how do
you turn that around so then as people
begin to open their heart
can that chemical begin
to
to
elevate
four days
50
change in the 120 people their their iga
levels went up 50 in four days
that's your body's immune system is now
up regulating genes that are making
proteins and immunoglobulins and
antibodies that you don't need a flu
shot in other words your inner state is
greater than your outer world so then
just by doing that we now know that your
immune system is going to get stronger
by the same means
take 120 people or 50 people and measure
7500 gene regulations
okay
in four days
two genes that suppress cancer growth
and tumors are activated and upregulated
the genes that stimulate stem cells that
go to damaged tissues and repair them up
regulate them the gene for oxidative
balance is upregulated anti-cancer
anti-aging anti-heart disease
anti-stroke anti-neurodegenerative
anti-inflammatory antimicrobial just
your body's naturally doing this
the gene for neurogenesis the growth of
new neurons in response to novel
experiences and learning this is four
days the gene switches on
the the gene for more balance in the
pituitary in the pancreas the gene for
the microtubules of the cells the
little little fibers that respond to
energy and frequency so in four days we
now know that you can change your
genetic destiny
if you just practice the inner work if
you're sitting in a meditation and your
body's thrown the kitchen sink at you
and saying ed you're a loser you're
never going to change this is too hard
why don't you quit and you're aware that
that's your body doing that and you say
to your body
we're going to sit here
and we're going to sit in this fire and
i'm going to keep applying the formula
and my your brain starts running to all
the emails you have to do and you become
aware of that and return back to the
present moment and you tell the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind now your will is getting greater
than that program and there's a
liberation of energy and every time you
do that that's a victory
and you teach every time you do that
that's a victory when your mind tells
the body i'm in charge when you say to
your when you you just want to get up
and you want to quit and you got no no
that's my body bring it back okay and
now you're now you're taming the animal
the body is the animal and you're like a
dog you sit
and if you keep doing this keep doing
this you're climbing on top and the body
finally acquiesces it finally says i'm
not going anywhere and then boom there's
this liberation of energy what's the
side effect
joy
person's heart just automatically opens
up and and
every time they do that those victories
add up there's no such thing as a bad
meditation there's only overcoming
yourself
and when you sit in the fire
and you work with that people say to me
why do you meditate every morning i said
because if i can overcome myself in the
morning the rest of my day is easy it's
easy true because because that's what
it's about you master yourself you
master your life yes and so then all the
chatter in your head that you listen to
all day long that is called the default
mode network in the brain our research
shows
that shuts off not just shuts off during
the meditation it stays shut off for the
rest of the day so the critic in your
head that's telling you this will never
happen you have enough time all right
that there's no voice there so you just
have a clear
flow of where you're going and you trust
yourself more we have research to show
that 60 days of meditation
five days a week will lengthen your life
the telomeres the little shoestrings on
the end of your dna get longer that
means your biological age is changing
so we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
i mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's having a transcendental moment
and we now know that we can predict it
and we now know that we can induce it so
then there's the evidence there
then you take
our community and you see people with
stage four cancer with parkinson's
disease with myasthenia gravis with with
lupus with ms with
brain injuries
with rare genetic disorders with vertigo
tinnitus
kidney failure all kinds of health
conditions
come to a week-long event
and then at the end of that event
they make significant strides in getting
beyond the emotions of the past now
think about this
the science says that the environment
signals the gene that's epigenetics
the end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion so as long as
you're living by the same emotion every
single day you're signaling the same
gene in the same way and if that gene is
related to a survival emotion a stress
hormone then you're down regulating the
gene and you're creating disease so when
the person trades that emotion and
really breaks free from the chains of
their past
and now they're feeling an elevated
emotion
well now they're dialing down the gene
for ms and they're up regulating the
gene for health and balance and so the
person will say to them where's the
disease well i'm not the same person i'm
not and and the side effect
of that is a transformation in healing
so
the funny thing about it is the person
who has the healing is not talking about
the healing
whether it's blind people seeing deaf
people hearing hearing we have crazy
evidence now
what they're talking about is how
amazing they feel
because
they're refreshed they're they're they
got a new lease on life and so now we
have evidence
in our research
and that silence is the critic to show
that what's possible for people i think
one of the challenges i think many
people have is really the discernment of
information
it's really difficult to know what's the
truth anymore just because
information is so accessible and i used
to say that in an age of information
ignorance is a choice and and now we
have to confront a whole nother level
and that is
the information that we're getting uh is
it is it actually supporting us or is it
something that really is an incentive to
to cause us to make choices so um for me
i think the biggest challenge has been
just really an awakening to
what kind of information i want to
expose myself to and i think it's now
more than ever a challenge for a lot of
people in the world if you have been an
experienced
uh if you had experience of trauma say
for example and it's created the feeling
of fear and your is that it could happen
again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now
all you need now is some cue in your
outer environment that says it's unsafe
that if there's damage there that you're
you're a victim something's bigger than
you that could have an effect on you
well now that feeling of fear
is going to cause you to think thoughts
equal to it
so the person then
no longer needs the environment
to feel that fear they just to have to
have the thought about
that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy a lot of resources to live in
emergency mode all the time guess what
system becomes compromised by the immune
system your immune system why because
you have two protection systems you
gotta get a system that protects you
from dangers in your outer world that's
that's the gas pedal that's the
sympathetic nervous system that's a
fight-or-flight nervous system danger
threat out there use all the energy
because you gotta you gotta survive and
when you survive you gotta take care of
your body so right so so now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined
whether your anger is valid or justified
or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says
well we're part of really the other
nervous system we're the brake we're the
clutch
we need the we need to get into
relaxation we need to get back into
balance again and and when we do then
we'll metabolize then we'll we'll
assimilate we'll reproduce we'll we'll
excrete properly
so
so now you got this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no homeland
security so they shut down
certain receptors in the immune system
they shut down function
of those lymphocytes those white blood
cells that are your inner army of
protection and it takes a lot of energy
to fight a virus in a bacteria but if
there's no energy hey listen it takes
energy to raise the body's temperature
where do you think that comes from
that's part of that branch called the
autonomic nervous system and the
sympathetic the gas pedal is part of it
and the parasympathetic is the clutch is
part of that autonomic nervous system
and it's a check and balance let's talk
about the neuroscience of culture
because there is a neuroscience to it
you have a brain that looks just like
the person sitting next to you
and if i was to screw off the top of
your heads
and take out your brain and your
partner's brain someone sitting next to
you and i went like this
and i set them out you probably wouldn't
be able to tell them apart
because you share the same structure in
your brain
and we call that universal traits we
call it gross anatomy now
because you share the same brain as the
person sitting next to you you smile
when you're happy you frown when you're
sad you sleep at night well this is
mexico you sleep kind of late at night
and get up kind of late in the morning
come on i'm kidding
and you know you grab a stick the same
way we speak a language and because we
share the same gross anatomy of the
brain we have very universal traits that
we have in common how many people are
with me
but now
how your brain is wired
is your individuality
and that's the minute architecture or
the minute structure of the brain
so then
your brain is wired different than the
person next to you because you have
different experiences
but if you share the same experiences
because you're in a relationship then
you have similar brains that are kind of
relating
and relationships are built on common
experiences
if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions and if we share
the same emotions we can relate with
each other
so then think about it like this
you have a hand
and because you have a hand you you have
the same hand as the person next to you
there's only a certain amount of things
you can do with your hand
but now
what makes you unique
is your fingerprint that gives you your
individuality and that is really the
minute anatomy
of something related to a hand are you
with me
so now
what is the division that unifies both
the universal traits
and our individual traits
and the answer is
culture
culture
and culture is defined by the
environment
in which you live
the environment in which you work
the environment of your family
an environment is made up of just a few
things are you ready
people
objects things
places
time
pets
and that's pretty much your environment
so the culture of mexico city
is defined by the environment
you eat certain foods you like certain
music
you relate with one another because of
the environment in which you live in
and that culture is created from the
environment which is different than the
culture of mongolia
because it's a different environment and
they have different traditions
they have different customs because
they've had to survive in a different
environment and so what unifies
individual individual traits and
universal traits is called culture now
think about this
most cultures are defined by the customs
they have the traditions the language
their survival skills their habits their
attitudes their beliefs their history
their arts their social structures that
have unified them as an individual
culture are you still with me
so the people you work with the people
you relate with the people you interact
with you share a similar culture that
bonds you both as an individual and as a
species called human beings and mexicans
are different than australians because
they live in a different environment and
they have different traditions
you still with me
but we could say then that culture
typically is defined by things that have
worked in the past
so then
most cultures then
have a choice
to create a new culture means then you
have to define your culture as a vision
of the future
but most people
their cultures are based on the past
present reality what does that mean we
are in a changing world and the world is
changing faster than most people can
keep up
and if you are going to stay defined by
a memory of the past you will not keep
up with this culture because we are
creating a global culture
so then
what defines
the vision of the future to change a
culture
and the answer is a very clear intention
a clear purpose
combined with an elevated emotion
and when you combine a clear intention
like a vision of the future
along with an elevated emotion of
inspiration and joy you will create an
empowered individual what's something
that you've said in the past that you
were confident about it then but now
upon reflection you're like oh i should
have changed my mind about that oh that
it takes a long time to create reality
i'm going to ask you to expand that
because i like that answer i want to
know more that's fascinating
well um i think just like anything else
you learn how to snowboard you go
through that learning curve you learn
how to ride a bike you go through that
learning curve
uh that that i used to think that
creation was hard
i just thought it took a lot of energy
and it took a lot of sacrifice and it'll
work for it and great onsen and uh god i
mean even my definition of surrender
today is very different than it was just
three months ago because i'm always
doing it
and so
i think that
it doesn't have to be that way i just
think that it could be any way you want
and that and then working on that
changing that belief the future then is
created by a clear intention and an
elevated emotion now listen closely
that you have to cultivate in your inner
environment of thoughts and feelings
but most people
by the old self are living from past
memories that are created from knowledge
and experience from something that
happened outside of them
some experience or trauma that defined
them and getting a person beyond the old
self then
is the great work that's what we're here
for
so
we've studied motivation
and i can tell you without a doubt
that the highest form of motivation
in any culture
in any group of people
is what's called purpose motivation
duty motivation or mission motivation
you know what that is
to have a vision to change a culture
that's bigger than you
to instill change in the world
look at elon musk how many people know
who he is
elon musk he created tesla motors
you know him
you know who he is
he created an electric car
that can go from zero to 60
in less than five seconds
and before him electric cars were like
golf carts
that you know crawled along the road
and he said
i'm gonna do this i don't know how i'm
to do it but i have a vision
and i'm going to get the best engineers
in the world
and instead of creating a new product
and selling it to a corporation
i'm going to get a group of people to
share the same vision as me
i'm going to change the world by
changing our reliance on oil
and i am going to make a difference in
the world and i am going to make a lot
of money
why not
and so people said no that's not
possible and he held on to that vision
and now motor trend magazine
never raided a car up close to a hundred
they rated the tesla car 103.
it's the best car on the road
and it relies on no gas at all that's a
vision of the future i got run over by a
truck and and and i broke six vertebrae
in my spine
and i had to make a decision at that
time in my life um
because the diagnosis wasn't very good
and neither was the prognosis and
to decide if i was gonna spend the rest
of my life on addictive medications and
with surgical rods in my spine or if i
was going to see if the mind could
actually heal the body and so that was
my wake-up call
in 1986 and so so i just um
i was at the point where i just had to
make a decision to see if it was
actually the truth if if all of this
that i learned was the truth let's let's
apply it and so i was lucky enough to
have a dramatic change in my own
personal health and then i thought god
if it worked on me as it worked on other
people so i started looking into people
that had you know been treating
conventionally or non-conventionally and
and with a certain diagnosis
and their condition was staying the same
getting worse and all of a sudden it got
better and and i just wanted to
look at what the cause was that was
producing that effect and so i
interviewed you know hundreds and
hundreds of people that had gone through
the process
and one of the most fundamental elements
that they all had in common with there
were a lot of things that had to do with
their mind and
uh and some people had specific diets
and specific regimes some people used
certain um you know conventional
non-conventional protocols but the the
commonality primarily was about how the
mind was really influencing the body and
and
they began to really take a closer look
at how
they were thinking
on a daily basis uh how they were acting
uh on a regular basis and looking at how
they feel
on a moment-to-moment basis and
and how you think and how you act and
how you feel is your personality and
your personality has a very direct
relationship with your personal reality
which means if you want to change your
personal reality if you want to change
something about your life you got to
change
and so the process of change then
becomes the fundamental process of going
from some person that's familiar and
known to you and stepping out and
beginning to make different choices and
to begin think different thinking
differently and being to behave
differently and speak differently and
feel differently and
and if you start thinking acting and
feeling differently our research shows
without a doubt
you're going to have dramatic changes in
your biology and if you do it enough
times you're going to become someone
else and the disease then all of a
sudden exists in the old personality
and not in the new personality and then
you ask the person where's the cancer
where's the rheumatoid arthritis where's
the immune mediated condition
it's in the old person i'm not that
person any longer personal conviction
motivation
we call these people self-starters this
is entrepreneurial motivation
this is when you say
i'm gonna do this because i said i was
gonna do it
still a high form of motivation but not
the highest form
but what we know
that people who have purpose motivation
naturally are personally convicted
their their personal conviction is in
alignment with their purpose because
they have a reason to get up every day
the recognition that
when you're assimilating a negative
thought or a negative judgment
or a negative emotion envy
greed whatever it may be
that's actually lowering your energy
yeah and when you get to that place
where you're experiencing that
incredible bliss right here you can you
can't yeah and even if you have the
thought and the thought will still come
because we still have those stories but
the thought
will be an understanding of human nature
because you're no longer
at that vibrational level anymore you're
rising above it you know and i think
more and more people are starting to
figure that out and and and the people
in their lives are like no my husband
my husband is a changed person no he's
not the same guy i know him i know he's
completely different and the guy's just
like yeah i feel amazing i feel great
and all it was was sitting in the fire
yes for a little bit of time until the
body finally moved out of the past into
the present moment and so
the causes of this like i always say you
never know
what you're doing today and how you're
doing it who you're going to affect
tomorrow when you do this work and
that's what we're seeing and people are
they're they're they're getting
promotions
uh they're getting all these wonderful
things not because
of anything that they're doing
they're just different yeah and people
notice that and they want those people
in the position to make better decisions
for the whole and i think that's uh
that's how we change the world here's
the deal with trauma and it's kind of an
interesting thing because when you're
traumatized
some threat or some danger or some
condition in your outer world
through your senses is changing how you
feel in your inner world
and the quotient of change between the
way you normally feel in some alarm
state when you change your internal
state and move into that emergency mode
you narrow your focus
on the cause and the brain
freezes an image and takes a snapshot
and that's called the long-term memory
and now that image is branded
holographically into the brain so then
they remember experience our experience
is better because we can remember how
they feel and and that memory then
changes the person's biology so they
think neurologically within the circuits
of that experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and how we think and feel
becomes our state of being
so now the person biologically has
changed and many times
it's the strong emotion that begins to
select and instruct the gene that
creates disease why
because if the environment signals the
gene and that's the truth that's
epigenetics and the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion
the emotion that you feel from that
event is literally selecting the gene
for you to begin to change and genes
make proteins and so the the person if
it's if it's strong enough begins to
wear their trauma not just in their
brain
now it's in their body because every
time they think about that trauma every
time they review it every time
they keep creating the imagery they keep
firing and wiring the circuits in their
brain
and they keep feeling the feeling
emotionally in their body and their body
is so objective
that it's believing it's living in the
same past experience 50 to 100 times a
day and all you need is a stimulus and
response
an image and an emotion a thought and a
feeling and you're conditioning the body
into the past well you're conditioning
the brain body into that bond university
a university in australia on the gold
coast
senior researcher took the large
majority of my brain scans
and they hadn't she had them analyzed by
her graduate students and they
statistically looked at everything
one of the most startling things for the
research team
was our community's ability
to go to
to get to that point where there's
nobody no one no thing nowhere in no
time now i'm talking four seconds i'm
talking five seconds i'm talking nine
seconds just like just give me a second
i know how to do this they they've
practiced it enough times that the
creative moment is when you get beyond
yourself when you dissociate from
everything known in your material world
turns out when you do that and you start
changing your brain waves
your brain waves slow down into alpha
and theta you're suppressing the memory
bank of the known self that keeps you
plugged into three-dimensional reality
when you quiet down this mechanism
now
all of a sudden you start connecting to
that field and when you can stay
conscious in those subconscious realms
when you can literally regulate and
change brain waves now you're in the
operating system where you can make
those significant changes why is our
memory
for
pain stronger than our memory of a
success or a joy i really think that
when the survival gene is activated
preservation is the key so we can have
10 things
that happen really great in our lives
you have a family member or somebody you
know that does this they have 10 really
great things happen in their one thing
bad and they focus on that bad thing why
because the survival gene is activated
they want to make sure it doesn't happen
again so so you put your attention on it
because
you don't want it to happen again so
what people do when they're aroused is
there to start thinking it's going to
happen so they actually select the worst
case scenario in their mind
and then emotionally embrace that future
before it happens and they're
conditioning their body to become the
mind of anxiety and fear so in
preservation and in survival if you
prepare for the worst
anything less that happens you have a
better chance of surviving so that's the
mechanism that takes place so
survival means you better take care of
your body yeah you better be aware of
your environment and make sure there's
no threats and so you got to keep your
eye out there
and you better be thinking about the
future based on what you learned in the
past now there's nothing wrong with that
when the analytical facilities are in
balance but when there's an arousal
arousal there's three things that create
arousal fear
hostility and anger or aggression and
pain
and that arousal drives the brain into
these high states of what we call high
beta
and most people need something or
someone or some circumstance or some
drug or some pill or some computer game
to change that internal state and the
moment they notice a change in their
internal state then they pay attention
to what's causing it they start
developing a dependency on it right
so
it turns out that when we teach people
how to self-regulate and change their
brain waves
we could actually see then that the
incoherence the disorderliness that's
taking place in the brain you know when
you're over aroused you're overly
analytical and you're shifting your
attention from one problem to one person
to one thing to one place to another
problem to another circumstance to your
phone to your car and each one of those
elements has a neurological network in
the brain so the arousal causes these
different circuits to fire out of order
and the brain is incoherent so take two
waves that are out of phase and mix them
when they interfere they flatten out
there's no energy so energy leaves the
brain right
so then
when you're in arousal you narrow your
focus on the cause if there's something
rattling in the bushes and it's dark you
freeze and you narrow your focus on it
and there's a rush of adrenaline and
your pupils dilate and your heart starts
to race and you're ready to run fight or
hide i mean that's a survival moment but
what if it's your co-worker
sitting right next to you or six feet
away and and you're judging them you're
the same arousal's taking place and
what's once very adaptive becomes very
maladaptive and this is where it gets
challenging so when we teach people how
to open their focus we've done
thousands and thousands of brain scans
and they get beyond their analytical
processes and they open their awareness
and go from a conversion focus to a
divergent focus and they learn how to
relax and regulate their brain waves
start to slow down into alpha and then
if they do it properly and they're
connecting
those different compartments of the
brain that were once firing out of order
start to unify different communities
form bigger communities the brain starts
to synchronize and then all of a sudden
you start seeing different compartments
of the brain all in resonance so now
when they're all in resonance and they
start interfering when those waves come
together there's more energy in the
brain
so when a person dials down the
mechanism this neocortex that plugs us
into three-dimensional reality that
keeps us aware of our body that's the
autobiographical self where everything's
stitched in memory in there when we
start deactivating the mechanism here
and we get beyond the memory bank of the
known self and brain waves move into
theta we've
we've studied this so much
when a person can let their body
be in a light state of sleep and feel so
safe
that you can finally let go and
surrender the body is
sleeping but the mind is awake and now
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is wide open and
if they can regulate and stay there
something amazing happens
there is a release of energy
from the body and their brain goes into
a very very super coherent state of
gamma and gamma is super consciousness
now i'm not talking about
a little gamma i'm not talking about a
lot of gamma i'm not talking about a
really loud gamma i'm talking about a
supernatural amount of gamma
there's so much order
and so much energy in the brain like if
we were in an audience and we were all
clapping like this
that could be alpha right theta would be
and if everybody could do this the
slower we could do it the more we can
get our timing down the more we can get
coherent but if we were doing
this it would be really hard for all of
us to do that at the same time it takes
a lot of order a lot of awareness a lot
of energy to be able to create that kind
of
order so
that's how fast the brain is and that
arousal
that's taking place is ecstasy that
arousal is bliss it is the most familiar
unfamiliar feeling that people ever have
in
that memory then
that the person has that is so
profoundly different
than the feeling of success
the feeling of wealth the feeling of
orgasm or love or whatever this is a new
one and it's a thrill
and the person notices a dramatic change
in their inner state
and with that experience comes a very
lucid picture
a very profound insight a download of
information
that's the moment then the body many
times rewrites the biological program
energy
is in forming matter and the autonomic
nervous system is regulating it's in
high order and remember disease is
autonomic dysregulation
now it's getting into a very very high
frequency of order and it's sending very
coherent information to the cells and
tissues sending energy to the cells and
tissues and cells begin to emit more
coherent light and information and then
there's the disease
and there it's not in our community at
least people who have relationships that
are built uh from our community
tend to be more long-lasting because
they're more self-aware and so there's
no blame there's no excuses there's no
make wrong there's no competition
there's none of that there's just this
is who i am you know and i think that
the ultimate goal is
when you reach the point in your life
when how you appear to the world
is who you really are that level of
transparency is it takes no effort right
you can be yourself and and
and you know people say to me wow you're
you're pretty approachable and i say
well god i work so hard every day on
overcoming myself in the morning
overcoming my ego why would i want to
build it up the next day because i got
to face that guy again tomorrow morning
so why not just keep you know you know
taking those edges and smoothing them
down so that so that
you're you're less
unconscious to all of those programs
that are built in relationships
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there